تشير ادويه التنحيف الى المكملات الغذائيه
التي تساعد على انقاص الوزن عن طريق منع
امتصاص الدهون او الكربوهيدرات او تقليل
الجوع او تسريع عمليه التمثيل الغذائي
النساء اللواتي تتراوح امارهن بين 18 عاما
والرابعه والثلاثين هم الاكثر استخداما
لادويه انقاص الوزن رغم ذلك لم يؤكد الطب
فعاليه اي منتج تنحيف بنسبه 100%
قدره قيمه سوق عقاقير انقاص الوزن
العالميه باربعه مليار دولار امريكي في
عام 2022 ومن المتوقع ان تصل الى 39.18
مليار دولار خلال العام الجاري يعاني اكثر
من مليار شخص على مستوى العالم من السمنه
في 2022
والنسبه تتزايد عاما بعد عام مع زياده
الوعي بالصحه قد تستقيمه السوق العالميه
في 2027 الى
65.16 مليار دولار منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ مسؤوله عن نصيب الاكبر في حصه
السوق الادويات انقاص الوزن العالميه خلال
2022 ومن المتوقع ايضا ان تكون المنطقه
الاسرى نموا في العالم حتى 2027